(audience cheers)
- Hello!
Well, hello and meet Kristin.
Have y'all ever met before?
- No.
- No, but I've seen him on stage and what,
your acting, you're such an artist.
You are so good.
(audience cheers)
- Thank you.
- I'm not lying.
She was talking about you
in the commercial break.
- Yeah?
- She was like,
"I'm so excited to meet him.
I'm so excited to come
out, for him to come out."
- Couldn't wait.
- Yes, I'm excited to meet you, too.
Actually, the other
day I was watching RV--
- Oh my God, I love.
- Oh my God, you saw that.
- And was laughing hysterically,
so it's, it's an honor.
- Thank you, honey.
- Yes.
- Thank you.
- Yes, yes.
And your theater legacy is incredible.
Thank you.
- That means a lot to me.
- Yeah.
Well, like Kristin, you
have also been on Broadway.
So it was actually the first time
Death of a Salesman had an all
African American cast, right?
- Yes, yes.
I mean.
- [Kelly] Did that feel like pressure?
- It felt like a lot of pressure.
I mean, this is a play,
it's one of the greatest
American plays ever--
- Ever.
- To be written.
- [Kristin] And your role--
- And my role as Biff is something
that a young actor just
dreams about being able to do,
let alone on Broadway.
So when we were gonna do the play,
first, you have to understand
this play has been done
so many times.
- 'Cause it's classic and great.
- It's classic and great.
So you've either read it,
you've either seen it,
you have either done it in class,
so you have your own
perspective on it, right?
So how do you do it new?
How do you change someone's
perspective on something
that's been done so well so many times?
- [Kristin] Right.
- And then on top of that,
it's being done with an all black cast,
so, then you have to have the question of,
"Is it going to resonate?
Will the language read the same way?"
So there was that pressure,
but I think what we all did with our show,
we didn't change any of the dialogue;
the script stayed the same,
but the nuances changed.
- Oh, yeah.
- You understand?
- Yes.
- So we all dug in, we gave
it everything that we had.
We gave our hearts, we gave our spirits.
And that's all you can ask someone to do
when they're on that stage.
(audience applauds)
- Yeah.
- Yes!
- And young black actors, now they see
that they can broaden the
scope on the kind of work
that they can do and
that they're able to do.
As long as the story, I believe,
speaks to our humanity on a deep level,
we'll all be able to understand it
no matter who's telling the story.
- Absolutely.
Nice.
I know, I'm like, gosh.
- So well spoken.
Right.
- Well you also, did I hear that you,
oh I got you, girl.
I cry all the time on this show.
Check it out.
- Sorry.
- Yep, yep.
They got a whole load
of 'em over here for me.
- It's just so well said.
- I know, I know.
So the new movie is
called Big George Foreman,
and it's about the life of, obviously,
former heavyweight champ, right?
- Yes.
Yes, it is.
- You like to take on some roles
that come with some like
pressure, like the bar is--
- [Khris] I do, I do.
- Do you do that on purpose
to challenge yourself?
- I do.
Yes.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- Because I feel for myself
that telling stories is a purpose, right?
And acting for me tends to be spiritual.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So when I connect to a role,
it's often instinctual
'cause I can feel a call to it,
I can feel a purpose to it, right?
So taking on this story
and telling the legacy
of Mr. Foreman, right,
from younger years all the way into 45.
- Yeah.
- I felt like there were
a lot of layers there.
There were a lot of--
- A lot of life there.
- Complexities and detail.
It's a lot of life there,
so there's a lot of things that
you can do with that, right?
Life change, I mean, year by year.
So, decade by decade.
So much happens.
- Was it hard to go from the young to old?
Like obviously the transformation of that?
- It was difficult to do that,
but the hardest part of that was
the weight transitions.
So we shot out of sequence, meaning
one week I could be 19
and then four days later, I have to be 32.
Which means, at 32, he's
a heavyweight champion.
At 19, he's not.
So I would have to shift my weight.
So week by week.
Yeah, that's, I put that weight on.
So, week by week, I would
go from being 225 pounds.
- [Kelly] Wait, what?
Wait.
- Yeah.
- No, no, no, no.
- [Khris] Wanna see it again?
- No, wait.
What do you mean?
Wait, somebody put that back up there.
Wait, what?
- Yeah.
- What do you mean?
That's you?
- That's me.
- That--
- A hundred percent.
- That's crazy.
That's awesome.
(audience applauds)
Awesome.
- Yeah.
- I want that part.
- I don't even know how to follow that.
Like that is incredible.
- I know.
- Like that's a lot of,
that's a lot on your body
to go back and forth.
Like that had to be--
- That's skill.
- How did you do that?
I mean, well, I can yo-yo
quite well myself, but like,
but like, I just mean like
that's a lot different.
- In a quick amount of time.
- [Kelly] That looks
like a different a human.
- So we finished the first block,
and I say first block 'cause
we filmed in two blocks,
and we took six weeks off
for me to gain the weight.
And like I said, I was
vacillating between 225 and 242,
depending on the age.
And that was week by week.
So one week I'd be 242
for all the heavyweight
championship fights
and then I would cut down
to about 228, 225 to
play the younger years.
And that was happening quite frequently.
- Oh my gosh.
- And we were filming like
five scenes a day sometimes.
So there were some days where
I couldn't cut down to 225.
- [Kelly] That's crazy, physically.
- Right.
So then it's like, how do I shrink myself?
'Cause I'm out there and I'm swole.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But I shrink myself to
be, you know, younger.
- So wait, then you took six
weeks off and that's when they?
- I took six weeks off, right.
- Oh, man.
- And I had a nutritionist and yeah,
they gave me a plan.
- How long did it take you to drop that?
- Well,
I was back down to 240
in about four weeks.
- Man, you have a very responsive body.
- Well--
- Like what?
It listens.
- I think because I had
trained for so long that
I put the weight on so fast,
that my body was ready to let it go.
So once I stopped eating
7,000 calories a day--
- Yeah, that's a, yeah--
- My body was like, all right, we're good,
we're good, we're good,
we're good, we're good.
And I had to--
- But it's like training
your stomach to not,
to shrink back, you know, too, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
That was the hardest part.
It just didn't wanna go anywhere.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It just didn't wanna go anywhere.
- Yeah, I feel ya.
- Yeah, yeah.
- All right, we have to
stop for another break.
But everybody, Big George Foreman
is in theaters starting April 28th.